voilà pour ce fameux documentaire alors
on va longuement se poser la question
avec les invités comment se construit
l'identité individuelle est ce que c'est
un millefeuille
est ce que tout ceci est une composante
de l'identité nationale ce fameux débat
nous avaient occupé en 2007 sous l'ère
de nicolas sarkozy et pour commencer à
en parler c'est michel wieviorka que
jeudi soir bonjour bonjour donc michel
wievorka j'ose même pas vous présenter
un vous êtes sociologue bien entendu et
président de la fondation maison des
sciences de l'homme
c'est bien ça tout à fait merci d'être
avec nous karim miské bonjour vous êtes
documentariste écrivain vous devrez
publié la part tenir aux éditions
viviane hamy
merci d'être avec nous fabien truong à
côté de vous professeur agrégé de
sociologie à l'université paris 8
vous êtes ancien professeur dans
plusieurs lycées de seine-saint-denis
merci d'être avec nous enfin je me
tourner vers les lycées sonné co
réalisateur du documentaire
bonsoir je précise toutefois toutes fins
utiles à nos téléspectateurs que nous
avions invité hugues lagrange sociologue
qui n'est pas dans cette lecture qu'on
vient de voir dans le documentaire à
participer à ce débat il a
malheureusement à notre grand dam
décliné l'invitation à quelques minutes
de l'enregistrement donc malheureusement
pour nous mais c'est pas grave ça va pas
nous empêcher de débattre et lycées
sonné je voudrais savoir qu'est ce qui
vous a poussé à suivre ces lycéens au
québec
je pense qu'un signe chez comme tous les
documentaires c'est des rencontres il se
trouve que moi je suis membre d'une
coopérative de production audiovisuelle
qui installé à evry en essonne dans un
quartier populaire sabah le parc aux
lièvres et on est en lien avec tout le
milieu associatif local vais donc
beaucoup de personnes qui travaillent à
ces questions là et c'est comme ça que
florine bacata est venu vers moi en fait
il ya deux ans avec un projet qu'il
était en train de lancer avec une classe
d'un lycée le lycée baudelaire à evry et
il m'a parlé de son envie d'emmener ce
groupe de lycéens à montréal pour leur
faire un peu vivre une expérience
différente de la diversité et puis à
partir et moi sommes enthousiasmés parce
que des questions qui me touche beaucoup
j'ai déjà fait plusieurs documentaires
sur ces questions là sur des femmes
immigrées ou sur une association qui
fait de l'accueil aussi de famille dans
un quartier populaire d'eric donc voila
moi j'étais tout enthousiasmé par par
son projet par le fait de travail avec
des jeunes avec un lycée d'evry
donc voilà avait toutes les raisons pour
y aller on a commencé à bosser avec
floride et du coup c'est ces lycéens là
que vous suivez ça veut dire qu'il ya eu
un travail au préalable sur les
questions identitaires avec les profs
avant le voyage au québec
voyez une première phase où c'était
vraiment floride lui les militants du
tout qui concerne les discriminations
avec son association qui s'appelle
réagir 91
donc il avait entamé déjà ce travail
avant de venir vers moi sur les
discriminations vraiment sûr avec toutes
les composantes qui peut y avoir que
soient bien d'autres orientations
sexuelles le culturel et c'est vraiment
un travail très large et puis après avec
moi on a engagé un travail vraiment sur
la question d'identité
donc on a passé beaucoup de temps avec
ces jeunes à intervenir et à discuter a
vécu à essayer de comprendre quel était
le regard là-dessus alors faire imaginer
les faire parler sur la question de leur
identité n'ont pas prêts ils ont tous
une 106 de différents qui sont en en et
17 à montréal
donc forcément ça 17 parcours différent
ils ont des histoires de familles
différentes ils ont aussi une apparence
qui fait que la question se pose plus ou
moins publiquement il y en a qui peuvent
pas garder pour eux d'autres forcément
on leur pose plus facilement donc il y
avait vraiment des des parcours
différents parce qu'elle sait ce qui est
très intéressant dans ce lycée en
particulier c'est qu'il ya ces réalités
professionnelles donc à un recrutement
très large c'est pas que evry on a des
gens qui viennent du sud de l'essonne
qui est plutôt rurale de famille un peu
aisée on a eu des gens qui viennent de
sites et donc c'est vraiment recrutement
large et c'est un concentré de la france
d'aujourd'hui et de demain
et ça qui était vraiment intéressant
c'est à dire faire des différences de
trajectoire quiron en plus d'expérience
en réussissant la fin vraiment il est
treize fois très variés ddm dd personnes
qui sombra d'origine franco française au
ch'ti etc
d'autres qui viennent d'europe de l'est
zones d'afrique du nord afrique
subsaharienne calment une grande variété
du métissage mais c'est ça qui était
super intéressant c'était de pouvoir
parler tous ensemble de ça et des
risques confronté en tant que groupe
un milieu différent décidé prouver notre
le choix du québec s'est fait
naturellement ou c'était déjà la séance
en raison du parcours de floride qui lui
dit elle pour le coup a aussi vécu une
rencontre avec le québec assez forte qui
lui a révélé beaucoup de choses sur sa
propre identité comme l'origine il est
originaire du congo zaïre et
voilà il a une expérience que je vous
vois ça serait un peu un peu loin a
expliqué mais voilà il a vécu beaucoup
de choses fortes à montréal il est très
important et pour lui ça reste un miroir
vraiment vraiment passionnant pour pour
notre propre rapport à l'identité donc
c'est pour ça qu'il m'a proposé dès le
départ c'était c'était montréal de
projets c'est assez drôle finalement
karim miské d'aller et prouver son
identité à 1000 kilomètres là
bon c'est vrai que ça marche en général
assez bien ils le disent tous dans le
film que tout d'un coup en allant là bas
ils se sentent français
bon ça c'est une expérience que beaucoup
de gens de diverses origines ont pu
éprouver effectivement ou à l'extérieur
pour des étrangers s'ils voient
quelqu'un qui parle français qui se
comporte comme un français qui vient de
france c'est un français finalement il
se pose beaucoup moins de questions que
qu'en france où on peut être beaucoup
plus renvoyer à son altérité réelle ou
supposée
fabien truong vous allez reconnu vos
élèves les élèves que vous nous racontez
dans je laisse française dans votre
dernier ouvrage ou ce que vous avez eu à
coacher quand vous étiez prof tzr donc
titulaire en zone de remplacement
seine-saint-denis c'est les mêmes que
vous aviez oui tout à fait facile et
même c'est pas les mêmes c'est à dire
que comme ça a été bien dit aussi des
trajectoires individuelles qui sont
aussi à chaque fois particulière mais
c'est vrai qu'on retrouve la même
tension et moi ce que j'aime beaucoup
dans le dans le film c'est qu'en fait
c'est une expérience de décentrement et
du coup elle est assez contradictoire
parce que comme il a été dit juste juste
juste là dans l'expérience des autres
mais on se rend compte qu'on est
français parce que il fait froid on
n'est pas habitué au froid ou qu'on
traverse rouge
enfin toutes ces petites choses là
sacrés français donc on est français et
de l'autre côté comme c'est une
expérience de décentrement il ya une
parole aussi qu'ils se libèrent et on
est légitime aussi on n'est pas tout à
fait légitimes à se dire comme français
et les deux choses s'entrechoquent en
permanence et par exemple il ya c'est ce
que me disaient les enquêtés ou anciens
élèves je sais pas trop comment les
appeler mais
ses revenus tout le temps ça on faisait
de temps on est français on n'est pas
français français je trouve que là ça
apparaît bien et je pense il ya une
dernière chose aussi qui était très
clair aussi un petit peu contre l'image
de des banlieues communautariste et voit
très bien aussi que c'est une mosaïque
c'est à dire que c'est
c'est à la fois on est français on n'est
pas français français on n'est pas ni
français ni français français de la même
façon exactement la même façon et donc
ça c'est je pense que l'on voit très
bien dans le film compliqué
effectivement michel wievorka quand vous
voyez la trajectoire de ces gamins est
ce que vous vous dites que c'est un
éternel recommencement est ce qu'on a
déjà vécu ça auparavant où il ya quelque
chose de nouveau dans ce phénomène de ne
pas sentir français je crois que quelque
chose de très nouveau depuis 20 ou 30
ans mais accuse de très nouveau qui est
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde et y
compris donc ces jeunes vie à la fois
ici et dans le monde
on est dans une période de globalisation
ne serait ce que parce qu'il ya les
médias la télé internet les réseaux
sociaux etc et donc de toute manière de
toute manière le décentrement de parler
il existe ça veut dire il ya cette
conscience là et c'est une conscience
qui vaut pour l'espace mais qui vaut
aussi pour le temps c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui il est plus facile de dire
je suis aussi un malien ou algériens ou
ceci cela que français donc ça ça me
semble plus neuf qui a bon il ya 50 ou
60 ans marie chevallier avait une
chanson et leur france était et tout ça
ça fait d'excellents français
bah c'est pas tout à fait ça pourtant
ils sont excellents français mais il ya
quelque chose de je crois de
relativement nouveau et qui a beaucoup à
voir je pense avec ce qui s'est passé
depuis le milieu des années 70 de dire
après les trente glorieuses la
transformation de l'immigration qui
était venu pour travailler et repartir
au pays c'était quand même ça
l'essentiel
les dernières vagues cette
transformation ces transformations et un
pays qui il faut le dire aussi va mal
qui n'a pas confiance en lui-même et des
économistes qui ont publié jacques
quelques années un livre sur la société
de méfiance ou de défiance ne sais plus
c'est un pays qui va mal qui n'a pas
confiance en soi quand on veut on prend
des sondages ils nous montrent que la
france est certainement en europe le
pays qui craint
plus la mondialisation mais ce genre de
choses et donc ces jeunes
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé le film je tiens
je tiens à le dire très publiquement je
les trouvais rafraîchissant surtout en
ce moment quand on faisait tout ce qui
se passe avec ses problèmes de migration
et d'exilés de réfugiés donc j'ai trouvé
ce film rafraîchissant et j'ai trouvé
l'idée excellente de mettre ces jeunes
c'est pas seulement des centres et suis
d'accord qu'il ya eu des changements
mais en position de réflexion en
position de d'analyser ce qu'ils étaient
en train de vivre c'est quand même très
très très très intéressant donc voilà
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau c'est
quand même très nouveau en même temps
alors justement j'aimerais pour lancer
cette question de comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure je suis français mais en
même temps pas vraiment français
je voudrais qu'on réécoute l'un des
lycéens qui a dit une phrase qui était
quand même assez forte
nous considérons malien le coche et
l'étranger la france est tout aussi des
repas thème des repas comprend c'est un
peu ce sentiment d'exclusion il est une
voiture à soulager relation plus vieille
simplement toc c'est comme ça j'ai nagé
plus vite mais les jeunes pousses est
même passée psion la housse en plus ce
ne sont pas des résidents ce qui se
passe lorsqu'on essaie de changer ce
sentiment nous ont fait le premier pas
sauf que là on apprend que j'allais
recul karim miské c'est un extrait assez
révélateur ces lycéens sont pour la
plupart nés en france
c'est un refus de la part de ces jeunes
de se sentir français quand on dit je
suis malien
quand je suis en france et je suis
finalement français quand je suis au
mali donc en gros c'est quoi c'est qu'on
est chez soi dans l'avion c'est la
problématique aller où là dedans
peut-être chez soi aussi dans son
quartier les identique à une identité
banlieusards les ai toutes les identités
territoriales sont quand même devenu
aussi très très forte mais bon comme on
le voit aussi dans la culture culture
américaine par exemple
qui est véhiculé aussi par la culture
hip hop c'est un élément assez important
de tout ça après je pense que on est
quand même quand on n'a pas l'air france
est confrontée quotidiennement au fait
de pas être perçu comme tel ce qui est
différent dans dans des pays
d'immigration comme effectivement le
canada ou les états unis où de toute
façon leur identité et de se construire
sur différentes sur l'apport de
différentes identités je pense que la
france est un pays d'immigration son
histoire le prouve mais bon avant
c'était pas visible c'est une
immigration majoritairement blanche
européenne et et et chrétienne ou juive
mais après bombay jules se sont
retrouvés un peu on va dire intégrer
dans plus ou moins mais dans le corps
français traditionnel comme disait
gérard longuet et après les et les
membres des autres vagues d'immigration
tout d'un coup il ya un truc qui s'est
bloqué c'est à dire qu'on les a toujours
renvoyé à une altérité essentiel salaire
comme si toute façon leur essence
faisait qu'il ne pouvait pas devenir
réellement français et un truc qui s'est
bloqué ben justement michel de voir qu'à
vous aviez écrit en 92 je crois à la
france raciste
le fait que ces jeunes soient pour la
plupart issus de minorités visibles
on va dire les choses clairement ça
renvoie au fait qu' ils ne sont de 2
facto pas intégrable où on n'en veut pas
c'est un effet miroir
s'ils ne se sentent pas français
finalement c'est parce qu'ils ne le
seront jamais assez parce que la couleur
indique qu'ils ne sont pas dans le
morphotype je dirais français qui
malheureusement du budget donc est ce
que j'avais fait à l'époque avec garder
toute sa fraîcheur malheureusement les
choses se sont simplement encore
dégradée mais je suis absolument mois
convaincu quand je vois les images de ce
film que tous ces jeunes son vol est
français désirent passionnément est
français sont prêts très très vite à
lever le drapeau en quelque sorte mais
que c'est la société française qui
contrairement à ce qu'ils voient de la
société québécoise
c'est la société française qui ne leur
permet pas de se sentir pleinement et ce
jeu vous coupable mais il ya une jeune
fille qui dit dans le documentaire
jeunes noirs musulmans banlieusards en
france on nous enferme dans des cases et
ont fini nous mêmes par s'y enfermer
tout à fait ce sont des gens qui ont le
sentiment à vue jeudi
c'est toutes les enquêtes que j'ai pu
faire le
montraient des jarries trentaine
d'années ce sont des jeunes à qui on dit
tu ne seras jamais complètement français
j'ai un collègue très connu pour ses
travaux sur la radicalisation parade
khosrokhavar qui termine une enquête sur
des musulmans de classes moyennes et
supérieures très intégrée qui ont réussi
les enfants vont dépenser dans des
bonnes écoles les ils ont des bons
salaires ils sont cadres et caetera et
presque tous disent il ya quelque chose
je ne me sens pas complètement à mon
aise
il ya quelque chose et je crois que
c'est un problème français et je pense
que c'est ce mois c'est ça qui me saute
à la figure quand je vois ce film c'est
ce décalage entre ce que disent ces
québécois et des problèmes à au québec
qui à du racisme et de la discrimination
aussi quand on va dans les campagnes
c'est pas tout à fait quand même quand
on va à montréal yann l'islam et à des
gens qui en ont une peur bleue il ya un
village au québec et s élève je me long
de ce ménage parce qu'ils avaient voté
requis est pas un musulman dans le
village il avait voté un texte locales
pour interdire la lapidation des femmes
donc il ya des angoisses et quand même
s'il société accueillant une société
ouverte et du coup les gens se sentent
complètement québécois y avait autre
chose qui joue aussi au québec c'est que
c'est une société minoritaire dans un
océan anglophone est donc une
particularité est donc faire un peu la
république fallait le petit village
gaulois francophone a siégé quoi ah bah
écoute et ils sont franck très
intéressant quand ils vous disent qu'ils
défendent la langue qui défendent la
langue française qui défie se sentent
très québécois c'est quelque chose qui
en france pour un autre tour et
justement les ambivalences qu'on
évoquait tout honneur fabien triangle
justement vous avez travaillé ce
qu'évoquait michel wievorka l'instant
sur ses jeunes
donc qu'ils ont pour la plupart réussi
scolairement et c'est là dans les
enquêtes que vous avez pu mener sur ces
gamins-là est ce que vous diriez que se
sentent intégrés français ou toujours
pas il manque encore quelque chose
en fait je pense qu'il faut un petit peu
décrisper les choses et view pour
revenir aussi ce que lea michele et le
requin en fait il dit où on a
l'impression qu'on vit dans une société
plus mobile plus international etc
mais c'est vrai aussi que ce sont des
jeunes qui sont constamment renvoyer en
fait à leur territoire
la banlieue le quartier dans les
discours publics donc là aussi je trouve
qu'il ya quelques jours une assignation
à résidence il faut bien comprendre la
violence en fait entre l'écart de tout
ce qui est la norme ou ce qui est censé
être le voilà les valeurs d'une société
cosmopolite et puisque ces jeunes en
fait en temps d'écouter en fait tu
prennes dans le visage dans les discours
qui les environne toute la nuit quelque
chose quand même assez violent mais je
disais aussi un petit peu décrisper les
choses parce qu'ils ont fait il sait ce
que je montre viens dans mon enquête je
crois c'est que ces jeunes aussi se
présentent sur des scènes très
différentes il ya par exemple dans le
film un moment donné un jeune qui parle
je crois que c'est une québécoise et
puis les 10 qui habite à paris
pourquoi il dit qu'il habite à paris
parce que ça fait bien habiter à paris
j'ai évidemment de la tour eiffel c'est
ici c'est les québécois se met en valeur
je pense que s'il était à evry il dirait
pas qu'il habiterait à paris et en même
temps je pense que profondément
il sent qu'il habite à evry n'est aussi
à paris et donc il faut bien regarder un
petit peu sur sur quelle scène on se
présente je vais prendre un exemple
parce que je pense que c'est plus
parlant d'un d'un jeune qui est dans l'
enquête qui s'appelle youssef al youssef
quand je parle avec lui quand je parle
il ya eu une discussion un moment donné
on parle du bac des études dumont c'est
après une sortie au louvre et à ce
moment là on discute il dit non mais moi
je peux pas dire je suis parisien je
suis je suis un bon oeil aux armées
parce qu'à ce moment là on parle d'un
certain parier le musée la culture un
peu le pari des profs
et puis s'ils discutent football avec
lui c'est pas un banlieusard c'est non
ses copains c'est papa sont des
parisiens ou des qataris vont ça
dépendra du degré de la vanne mais lui
il se dit marseillais parce qu'on va t
il supporter l'om donc
il ya marseillais ça marrant ce
millefeuille identitaire mais par contre
autre autre exemple quand on est là ça
me surprend parce que je montre dans l'
enquête
on discute c'est la fin de l'année et
puis je n'entends plus rien je suis un
parisien et c parisiens mais tu m'avais
dit tu pourrai jamais dire que tu es
parisien et on discute et pourquoi il se
dit parisien parce qu'à ce moment il
parle du bled est en fait il parle de
son rapport au bled et en fait parce que
la famille va venir on y va y aller et
en fait qu'il y aille ou qu'ils m'en
dire qu'il que sa famille vient quand sa
famille vient et comme il le dit allez
visiter le parc de la courneuve on va au
chant va et donc j'habite à paris
et quand il est au bled comme il me le
dit balla façon en finlande sa façon de
marcher sa façon de parler
son accent aussi on arabe fait de lui un
parisien et donc il joue un petit peu
avec ça et c'est vrai que je pense que
dans les discours publics dans le on a
toujours des choses et socialisante
c'est spécifique aux banlieusards entre
guillemets parce qu'on peut retrouver ça
aussi je crois on creuse enfin je sais
pas je pense que quand on quand on se
regarde un petit peu soi-même on est
enfin si tout le monde est honnête soit
avec soi même on parle jamais de la même
façon avec sa famille avec ses amis avec
ses collègues dont 1 c est quelque chose
qui est proprement humain enfin chien
c'est presque la base de la sociologie
mais c'est vrai qu'on fait un petit peu
de ces jeunes de banlieue des espèces un
petit peu différente de ceux conduits là
c'est pas quelque chose de bon lieu
spécifique après le fait d'être de vivre
dans dans dans un dans un lieu qui est
stigmatisé qui est dynamique mais à
l'eau douce point de vue l'annoncé par
un bon je suis suivi comment vous l'avez
perçu vous ai dit ce n'est justement à
la lorsque vous les avez filmé sur ses
mille feuilles identitaire est ce que
certains en fait on voit qui se sent
victime un peu les portugais d'un côté
les noirs de l'autre les arabes etc
c'est quelque chose d'assez naturel
finalement oui moi je pense que pour
avoir moi même grandi en banlieue c'est
un
ça c'est un état de fait c'est quelque
chose qui on est multiple on appartient
à toi tout ce que tu viens de raconter
sur paris la banlieue marseille parce
que papa rifains voilà c'était un jeu
qui se fait pour pour ce exister dans le
groupe après moi je voulais revenir par
rapport à leur sentiment d'être français
je pense qu'en france on a quand même
une grande spécificité c'est la place du
fn depuis 30 ans et même si une grande
partie des populations jeunes blanche
d'origine française il ya aussi une
difficulté à adhérer aux symboles
républicains parce qu'ils ont été
récupérés par le fn est donc vraiment on
demande à ces les jeunes qui sont
d'origines variées quelque chose que
plein de jeunes d'origine française ne
font pas non plus en fait
moi j'ai jamais revendiqué haut et fort
oui je suis français j'adore la france
on m'a jamais rien demandé de tel
pourquoi est ce qu'il pourrait faire
plus après ça c'est un cheminement qui
vont faire ils ont 18 ans à 25 30 35 ans
ils auront des enfants
petit à petit vont ils vont se sentir
français comme moi même dans mon
évolution je peux plus cela permet donc
je pense qu'on leur demande aussi des
choses qui qui pose pas vraiment
problème c'est normal de se poser des
questions c'est des jeunes adultes ils
sont dans un entre-deux ils sont dans
une situation territoriales qui
compliquait est pour moi le il faut il
faut pas en rajouter par rapport à
toutes ces questions là est moins utile
ces jeunes que ce que j'observe et que
je on a pu filmer à montréal finalement
il ya une mosaïque de témoignages très
variés quand on écoute dans le film il
ya plein de la vie qui se complètent et
c'est pas une seule c'est pas un langage
unique
c'est très très variable justement est
ce qu'on dirait par rapport à ce que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure michel
wieviorka sur la particularité
québécoise en france on parle
d'intégration on parle d'assimilation
ans au québec on parle
d'interculturalisme ailleurs on peut
parler de multiculturalisme
finalement c'est quoi le modèle français
le vent c'est ce qui va mal mais les
français dit d'intégration républicaine
jean nolet qui va mal qui est en crise
on vole haut de tous les deux il prend
l'eau de toutes parts
non pas parce que les valeurs de la
république serait mauvaise mais parce
que les le discours incantatoire qui
vise à plaquer sur des réalités qui s'en
éloigne ce modèle devient une promesse
couple est marty fille ciel complètement
abstraite veut pas dire aux jeunes
liberté égalité fraternité elle
deux journées face à nada français
républicain d'intégration leur dire vous
vous êtes tous des individus libres et
égaux en droits vous avez des
appartenances identitaires mais c'est
privé dans l'espace public nous sommes
tous pareils et c'est alors que les
réalités vont complètement dans une
autre direction
donc ça ne marche plus donc il faut
réfléchir à cette question est d'une
certaine façon je ne dirais pas qui est
un modèle québécois parce que je pense
que c'est aussi quelque chose de
compliqué à cerner mais on a quand même
le sentiment d'une société qui au québec
et c'est ce que découvrent ces jeunes
réussi mieux que la société française à
faire sa place au différend qui a un
superbe dialogue y compris les images
qui m'ont beaucoup plu où on voit deux
jeunes filles qui seraient totalement
interchangeables une porte à un foulard
et notre n'a pas elles ont habillées en
blanc vale se ressemblent elles sont
face à face est très très beau et la
jeune fille québécoise explique ben y'a
pas de problème porte le foulard elle
tout à fait à son âge au lycée bon et
bien voilà donc la france est un pays
qui s'est crispé de manière très
idéologique sur ce modèle républicain
alors vous avez raison d'ajouter qu'en
plus depuis quelques années tout le
monde est républicain c'est quand même
quand on sait qu'en france était la
guerre la guerre des deux france c'était
ça c'était les républicains contre la
france chrétienne fois vous c'était bon
alors aujourd'hui la droite s'appelle
les républicains et marine le pen est la
meilleure comment guéret défense
défenseurs de la laïcité la république
pour deux évidemment facile justement on
va en parler mais karim vous qui avez au
travers de votre ouvrage et essayer
d'explorer cette question identitaire
qui qui vous occupe beaucoup depuis
depuis pas mal de temps
comment est ce qu'on arrive à savoir si
on parle d'intégration d'assimilation
est-ce qu'il faut parler d'inclusion
comment est-ce que vous personnellement
vous l'avez ressenti
vous vous sentez intégré alors je
rappelle juste que vous êtes mauritanien
par votre père français par votre mère
et vous avez toujours donc aussi y est
vous le raconter très bien dans ce
nombre dans cet ouvrage entre cette
question de où suis-je et qui suis-je
quel moment enfin en a vraiment le
sentiment fait que c'est une trajectoire
et c'est un travail qui est finalement
assez long donc qu'est ce que vous
diriez aujourd'hui vous que vous êtes
intégré assimilés inclus c'est comment
vous vous ressentez ben on dirait mon
expérience est un peu particulière et
justement pas très représentative parce
que j'ai grandi dans une famille plutôt
classe moyenne aisée blanche française
la famille de ma mère mes parents
étaient séparés donc j'étais vraiment
juste confronter au regard de l'autre
c'est à dire c'est le regard de l'autre
qui me renvoyait à une altérité que moi
en réalité dans ma vie quotidienne je
n'éprouvais pas parce que sauf que
effectivement j'avais pas exactement la
même tête que le reste de ma famille ni
le même nom puisque mon prénom est
musulman jeu bah voila j'ai grandi ma
mère était marxiste hâte et sans aucune
éducation religieuse
à la limite ce que je connaissais un peu
mieux c'était le christianisme même si
ma famille était plutôt déchristianisée
donc je pourrais pas dire que je suis
intégré ou assimilés je suis français
j'ai grandi là d'avant c'était ma
réalité et en même temps avec ce truc
bizarre que finalement dans le regard de
l'autre je sentais bien que ça
correspondait pas que j'étais ailleurs
je veux pas dire évidemment je me suis
construit aussi avec des apports du côté
mauritanien mais quand même nettement
moins mon père était toute en voyage
après parents avaient divorcé donc il
n'était pas tellement là c'était plus
dans les récits mamère finalement que
j'avais un rapport à la mauritanie mon
père est exilé politique j'allais là-bas
pour la première fois j'avais 15 ans
donc j'ai découvert ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le bled assez tardivement au
tout d'un coup on me disait que non en
fait j'étais arabe et musulman ex
terrasse qui pour moi ne correspondaient
à aucune réalité on n'y avait pas
vraiment préparé donc
donc voilà c'est un peu une espèce de
cas chimiquement pur je dirais presque
de ce que c'est que justement d'être
confronté à l'altérité dans le regard de
l'autre
et c'est après ben
comme on le voit bien dans le chine je
pense que beaucoup de gens vis des
parcours différents après juste pour
pour revenir sur la comparaison moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé film sur sa super ferait
effectivement et je trouve ça très bien
d'être dans ses paroles diverses des
jeunes mais ça m'a fait réfléchir sur la
question de la violence bon je parle pas
mal de saad en appartenir je crois que
là pour moi la question de l'identité et
de l'appartenance elle est liée à celle
de la violence
elle est liée à un chantage y compris
vers dans les identités de genre c'est à
dire quand on appartient à un groupe ça
veut dire qu'on pourrait éventuellement
considérer ceux de l'eau groupe comme
des adversaires ou des amis à qui on
pourrait faire du mal voir les éliminer
en gros en résumant 1
on voit bien dans les guerres de
religion dans tous les conflits
identitaires et ces mêmes ventes ul mans
dans le rapport comme je raconte dans un
exemple entre garçons et filles à
l'école ou voilà on se construit comme
ça dans le regard de l'autre comme étant
un adversaire et c'est aussi comme ça
qu'on ce qu'on se définit je pense qu'en
france il ya cette question de la
violence fondatrice qu'est la violence
coloniale
c'est quand même ça qui est au coeur des
questions identitaires réduit est comme
ça s'est passé dans des territoires hors
de la métropole c'est quelque chose
qu'on a tendance à refouler un peu
facilement passait pas comme aux états
unis il est l esclavage s'est passée sur
le sol américain donc il pouvait pas
faire comme si elle même si vous voulez
parler pour être clair ça veut dire que
là par exemple dans ces cas là comme ce
sont des gamins issus pour la plupart de
minorités qui sont d'anciennes enfin
colonies il ya une dimension qui est lié
à cette histoire aussi par wi fi lière
de la colonisation et de la violence
coloniale parce que la colonisation
c'est quand même un système fondé sur on
va dire l'anthropologie raciale enfin en
tout cas sa réalité une justification a
posteriori mais les cas voir partir dans
des trucs techniques c'est l'école
psychiatrique d'alger par exemple qui
disait que le cerveau d'un arabe et est
constitutivement inférieur à celui d'un
européen donc c'était ça la colonisation
quand même c'était l'idée que un
colonisé est inférieur structurellement
et ça c'est encore ancrées oui pour moi
ça c'est ancré sa s'est transmis de
manière visible ou invisible
après juste pour faire la comparaison
avec le québec peut-être pourquoi ça se
passe mieux au canada c'est que là on
n'est pas sur une question qui concerne
les ce qu'ils appellent la balle est
première nation c'est-à-dire les
autochtones c'est à dire que la violence
fondatrice là bas elle était contre les
amérindiens
c'est un autre type de violence et tout
d'un coup il ya des populations qui
viennent de partout mais qui elles ne
sont pas inscrits dans cette histoire de
violence et elie puis fabien sur cette
question
ce que vous dites sur l'histoire
coloniale je pense que même ces mêmes
l'histoire républicaine en france
peut-être qu'on oublie trop souvent on a
ce type de modèle de lune de l'unité
nationale de la france une et
indivisible mais on oublie que depuis la
monarchie absolue en passant par la
révolution et la république ça s'est
fait par les armes
on a imposé le français aux
provinces-françaises par la violence
donc on a cette impression que la france
c'est un ensemble homogène où tout s'est
toujours passé naturellement mais c'est
pas vrai et donc aujourd'hui de devoir
de la diversité de voir des parcours
hétérogènes et dé façon hétérogène de
vivre la france
ces choses qu'il faut qu'on apprenne
nous dit finalement que cette violence
inhérente à l'histoire de la société
française on l'a reproduit aussi sûr c
est qu il ya un modèle à revoir parce
qu'on a construit un modèle d'unité
ouais et qui aujourd'hui marche plus
parce qu'on est en 2015 c'est la
mondialisation ça peut plus fonctionner
donc il faut se remettre en question je
pense pareil instruire oui aussi pour
revenir sur cette question la violence
est en fait ce qui était dit sur le
cette transmission un peu de violence
il ya un passage trouve qu'être très
beau dans le film c'est boucar diouf
donc c'est le sait le comique et puis il
parle du rapport entre les parents et
les enfants l'adorent
il utilise le vous permettez fabien on
va le réécouter tout cela fait quand on
dit je peux prendre l'expression de la
phrase qui disent tout à il faut qu'ils
épousent les valeurs républicaines on
entend ça ne pourrait pousser les
valeurs républicaines il faut que la
république retrouve une valeur à nous ça
donne ça donne envie de le faire parce
que sinon les gens ils ne feront pas ce
que je veux dire c'est que pour que
quelqu'un embrasse une culture et se
semble habité par le drapeau et la terre
faut qu'il soit bien et s'il n'est pas
bien il ne fera pas et s'il n'est pas
bien
non seulement il ne faudra pas mais ses
enfants ne le font pas parce qu'il va
les éduquer la nostalgie est ce que ça
crée souvent c'est ce qu'on appelle une
erreur identitaire une errance identité
à fabien triangle oui et puis c'est le
le mode nostalgie que je trouve très
beau et très juste c'est qu'en fait il
est très évocateur on voit pas les
parents en fait là dans l'eau dans le
film mais c'est vrai qu'elle ce rapport
en fait parce que quand même la plupart
des garçons et des filles qui viennent
de ces quartiers qui vient ici on lit
c'est donc en fait moi par exemple dans
mon enquête
il ya dans tous les lycées ou en fait
j'ai enseigné sur 10 par an il y en
avait en moyenne 2 en fait qui est
qu'ils avaient le niveau du bac
donc en fait ce sont quand même des
jeunes aussi à travers leur train leurs
trajectoires scolaires qui s'éloigne au
fait de leurs parents pour plein de
raisons
et il ya beaucoup aussi de non-dits
alors aussi parce que pour un certain
nombre de garçons notamment même si de
fait il ya beaucoup de choses qui
passent dans les non-dits avec le père
avec la mer etc
et c'est air de nostalgie est très fort
et les enfants le centre est par exemple
pour la hausse concerne la pratique de
l'islam qui est mon l'a dit tout à
l'heure
très souvent stigmatisés perçu comme
comme un problème c'est très souvent
pour un nombre de garçons une façon un
petit peu de reconnecter est en fait un
moyen des choses ici terre-à-terre avait
avec le père notamment pour les garçons
sur fréquenter la mosquée juste pour
juste pour créer du lien
voilà une heure ou deux a porté la
djellaba et c'est alors que quand on va
aller avec les copains on va passer
nécessairement porter la job un petit
peu ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
les scènes et ça on peut percevoir aussi
la violence entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur vous voyez ce genre de
pratiques et moment donné sont très
fortes pour des adolescents qui sont en
train de se construire de retisser un
lien
et quand de l'extérieur si on voit aller
à la mosquée avec une djellaba quand
même
on a tendance à penser terrorisme c'est
en parlant de violence encore enfin il
ya le hiatus entre ce que vous vivez de
votre pratique et ce qui est perçu de
l'extérieur est extrêmement extrêmement
violents et donc oui c'était peu mais ça
passe par des petites choses je pense
souvent invisible michel wievorka pour
revenir sur la dernière phrase de stu
maurice il dit si les gens sont pas bien
il faisait lui qu'on leur enfant dans
une nostalgie ça conduit à une errance
identitaire est ce que on voit ce que je
comprends c'est que peut-être que
finalement on a un peu aussi maltraité
ses parents à un moment quand je me
remémore le bruit et l'odeur de jacques
chirac des slogans du front national sur
trois millions de chômeurs 3 millions
d'émigrés est ce que ces discours qu'on
a pu entendre dans les années 80 ont pu
aussi éloigner les parents qui du coup
ont aussi va éloigner leurs propres
enfants de cette identité là écoutez les
jeunes qu'on voit en tout cas il
n'apporte pas une réponse positive à ce
que vous dites ils sont ils son placard
bien je tout ils réfléchissent ils
discutent
moi je trouve qu'une capacité
d'analystes formidable à simple étude
est bon ils ont tenu des bons profs
enfin quand même et évidemment il ya eu
des difficultés à tout le poids de
l'histoire qui vient d'être évoqué quand
même énorme chez nous et je pense que si
vous mettez le poids de l'histoire
le racisme les discriminations les
logiques sociales d'exclusion comme les
gens qui sont venus pour travailler puis
acquis en à dire bonjour il ya plus de
boulot bon et cetera les paires
discréditer enfin toutes ces choses bien
connu je pense qu'en gros les parents
ont eu à choisir chiche simplifier un
tout petit peu entre trois orientations
possibles
la première c'est celle que vous venez
d'évoquer la nostalgie c'en était dans
la psychanalyse en duvet la mélancolie
mais je me tourne vers le passé je
m'enferme je me replie et je n'en sors
plus sinon par la violence que je vais
pratiquer ou le sectarisme ou ou we had
et il ya des sectes non-violence de mai
du sectarisme aussi bon dans tous ces
milieux ça c'est une première fois la
deuxième voix c'est celle qui est
impossible
on en a parlé c'est l'assimilation c'est
à dire se dissoudre oubliez ça veut dire
oublie on peut pas oublier surtout dans
ce monde de médias de bons et la
troisième voie je reste dans papa plus
autant que ça dans les catégories de la
psychanalyste c'est le 2
c'est à dire je suis capable de me
souvenir mais je me projette vers
l'avenir
je prends en compte le passé je suis pas
dans la nostalgie tue pas la mélancolie
mais je n'oublie pas la colonisation
mais je me construis et toute la
discussion qu'on a je trouve que je
trouve vraiment très très bien me donne
à penser qu'il faut en finir avec les
catégories intégration assimilation et
que le mot identité
peut-être même pas ce que ça
essentialiste et vous qui disiez tout à
l'heure ça naturalise on met les ans
dans des boîtes d'un type ou d'un autre
1 alors que si ces gens se construit les
gens se transforme se construit moi je
préfère qu'on parle de processus de
subjectivation où ils deviennent soudain
sujets deviennent sujets de leurs
existences sont capables de la pensée
donc d'être dans la réflexion dans la
réflexivité moi c'est ça qui me
semblerait la porte à bien trois oui oui
pour enfin pour aller dans ce sens là
c'est je pense qu est ce qu on voit bien
dans le film se dire que en france on
parle beaucoup de ces grands débats ces
débats ancion etc et on voit que c'est
un petit peu de pragmatisme dans ces
choses là et c'est une question de
petits pas en fait
je crois que ceux ci dont l'extrait
qu'on a vu un petit peu après
l'humoriste dit c'est une question de
temps et c'est un pas vers l'autre en
arrière et ses essais ses questions
voilà deux processus ce sont des pas et
aussi peut-être pour parce que c'est
vrai que dans le film on il ya quelque
chose de très positif et il faut aussi
le dire parce qu on a aussi beaucoup
parlé d une des choses qui allaient mal
mais il ya aussi et ça c'est très
visible aussi on ne voit pas trop dans
les discours mais ce que j'essaye aussi
de montrer dans mon enquête parce que le
sous titre de mon livre c'est le bac +5
made in banlieue il ya des banlieusards
qui viennent de milieux populaires ou
issus de l'immigration qui arrive au
niveau bac + 5
qui est qui et quand même ce qui est
attendu socialement etc et qui alors je
n'aime pas ce mot l'âge mais je mets des
guillemets donc du coup qui s'intègrent
fondateur qui se dilue dans la société
française ce qu'ils trouvent leur place
en fait tout simplement qu'ils trouvent
leur place et ce sont les contrôleurs de
la sncf qui s'appelle lakhdar l'école
des cadres commerciaux qui s'appelle
myriam fares était et qui sont là par
contre ce qui est très difficile quand
on suit leur trajectoire et tous ces
petits pas en fait c'est quoi faire des
études
c'est que c'est c'est que c'est très
difficile c'est à dire que c'est vrai
qu'on a le discours de l'école qui de 10
si tu es bon tu arriverais l'école pour
c'est un levier mais c'est difficile
si on prend par exemple dans mon enquête
les jeunes qui est qui font les parcours
les plus excellents par rapport aux
canons scolaire au type des classes
prépa sciences po etc
les épreuves les plus difficiles en fait
pour réussir à tenir dans les études qui
ne sont pas les épreuves scolaires des
épreuves académiques ce sont des
épreuves social de confrontation à
l'altérité sociale et quand vous venez
de banlieue et que vous avez la passion
n'est pas laid c'est même pas seulement
vous n'avez pas les normes c'est dire
que tout de suite vous sentez le poids
du regard d'être très différents nous
vivons fait sentir que vous n'allez pas
vous n'êtes pas comme les autres je
n'allais pas y arriver et c'est très
difficile on voit très bien dans l'
enquête comment les deux premières
années on a des enfin voilà des
étudiants des étudiantes en pleurs et
eric il a dit non mais c'est aussi
l'intérêt de regarder les choses dans le
temps long et c'était le coeur de mon
enquête pas faire une enquête juste sur
deux trois ans mais sur 5 6 7 ans 8 ans
pour certains c'est ces deux oui on peut
lâcher un moment donné et revenir fait
et c'est tout ça c'est le temps c'est à
dire que quand on était jusqu'à un bac
on a quand même des ressources comme
vous l'avez dit on réfléchit il ya des
choses qui peuvent être difficiles mais
aussi dans le temps long je pense qu'il
ya des choses aussi mois de la dilution
aussi très
pacific wyeth manière mais qui se fait
et lycées on est rapidement
non c'était pour pour rebondir je pense
que par rapport à ce qui paraît sur
l'expérience des parents etc
il ya aussi quelque chose de très
naturel en fait ce que on arrive à une
nouvelle génération qui simplement
veulent être regardés comme comme une
normalité
il revendique simplement ça et c'est
chose qui n'avait pas lieu avant en
dehors de toutes les difficultés que
peuvent connaître une partie de ces
familles parce qu'il ya aussi une grosse
partie qui est deux qui a intégré fin
qu'on peut appeler intégré qui en tout
cas qu économiquement en place etc
mais avant tout c'est juste de dire
regardez comme tout est normal oui et
qu'il soit inclus dans l'équation j'ai
envie de dire en fait simplement c'est
par une anomalie c'est pas quelque chose
qu'il faut régler simplement l'incluant
dans la façon de se regarder en tant qu'
en tant que france multiple ans alors il
ya une nouvelle catégorie qui a
peut-être remplacer le banlieusard le le
noir la rave cette figure de l'autre
qu'on avait c'est depuis quelques temps
le musulman et on évoquait tout à
l'heure cette séquence dont vous parlez
michel llorca entre cette jeune fille
voilée dans le lycée de québec fin de
montréal pardon et cette jeune fille du
lycée d'evry est-ce qu'on a remplacé la
figure de l'autre par le musulman
michel wievorka je ne sais pas si on l'a
remplacé mais en tout cas c'est l'islam
qui aujourd'hui est au coeur des
discours de peur de n2 sentiment
d'inquiétude très clair il ya 40 ou 50
ans on aurait dit les arabes
aujourd'hui on dit les musulmans ça qui
veut dire ce qui veut dire c'est
compliqué parce que l'islam c'est une
religion
donc est-ce qu'il s'agit vraiment que de
ça et c'est à dire est ce que la hantise
de l'islam c'est uniquement la hantise
d'une religion ou est-ce que ça n'est
pas en réalité on n'aime pas tellement
le mot d'islamophobie
je le trouve pas tout à fait adapté mais
ce que derrière cette hantise de l'islam
il n'y a pas une sorte de de
condensation de haine raciale
comment raciale donc on essentialise la
religion d'une certaine façon
pour en faire quelque chose qui est
l'objet de peur dans lesquelles le
racisme doit trouve quand même la nature
trouve aussi sa place n'est pas
uniquement dans la religion mais
effectivement il ya cinquante ans
c'était pas l'islam d'abord il y avait
très peu de d'islam en france
aujourd'hui c'est l'islam et en même
temps c'est vrai que c'est un peu ce que
vous laissiez entendre l'islam dont un
certain nombre de personnes n'y a pas
que c'est la solution ou la réponse mais
c'est ce qui permet de se défendre de
résister de se maintenir se construire
aussi parce que d'être aussi peut-être
dans une forme de communauté qui
pourrait créer deux on était différente
est différent et puis qu'un beau jour
mais où je suis différent je suis du
genre je suis musulman c'est ma religion
ça vous donne une fierté ça peut donner
une fierté une solidité
si l'appartenance à une communauté fin
des choses qui finalement vous vous
soutiennent donc je pense que pour le
dire autrement que la société française
a contribué en partie oui à la
fabrication de l'islam qu'ensuite elle
combat pour ceux qui en ont peur
je voudrais alors être rapidement oui
pour rebondir en fait une pièce qu'est à
de très pratique une certaine manière
dans la figure de l'islam c'est que
c'est un peu une image internationale
pour le coup parce que du 11 septembre à
madrid en passant par londres à des cetc
on n'a ni figure comme ça qui à laquelle
on peut se faire un tous les jours en
fait en regardant le
le journal etc on peut voir enfin
retrouver dans des images
cette peur d'eux mais du coup le record
il ya on est toujours dans des
raccourcis parce qu'évidemment la
pratique de l'islam en banlieue
parisienne par des jeunes qui est en
train de faire des luttes par exemple et
la pratique de l'islam à des fins la
même chose voire même pas du tout les
mêmes choses et en même temps ce
raccourci dans une société qui va vite
où comme le dit à beaucoup
d'informations il ya quelque chose de
très pratique pour homogénéiser les
discours et nourrir des peurs et donc là
je pense qu'il faut toujours faire la
distinction entre ces images et ce qui
se passe véritablement il nous reste
quelques minutes
comment peut-on créer un sentiment
d'appartenance chez séché ces lycéens
chez ses enfants chez ces jeunes adultes
est ce que c'est la question de la
représentativité des communautés parce
qu'à un moment on entend la possibilité
d'avoir des journalistes noirs ou des
sportifs ou des hommes politiques est-ce
que ça passe par ça car initier les
sportifs s'amendent pas me poser
problème à certains
je pense que oui la question de la
représentation c'est clair très central
c'est vrai que le fait de grandir dans
un pays et de ceux de voir des gens qui
vous ressemblent bon je pense que ces
centrales
effectivement bon dans notamment dans la
fiction journalistes etc mais aussi dans
le personnel politique est là je pense
que ça pose un autre problème c'est à
dire quel type de personne vous
représente et je pense que pour le
moment si on prend un peu un langage de
la rue beaucoup de gens ont l'impression
que les noirs et les arabes qui sont
admis à faire une carrière politique on
va dire sont plutôt ce qu'on appelle des
bounties c'est-à-dire à l'extérieur mais
des gens qui finalement voilà renonce en
fait à admettre quelque part qui sont
qui représente aussi ces gens qui leur
ressemblent et que c'est pas du tout
contradictoire avec le fait de
travailler pour la nation française dans
un sens plus général
vous l'avez ressenti ça va aller chez
jeu ces gamins qu'ils avaient besoin
comme ça de deux figures un peu
tutélaire auxquelles se raccrocher
moi je pense que c'est simplement se
reconnaître à un moment j'ai mes parents
ma fille est métis et je vois
l'importance pourrait devoir des
publicités
où elle peut se reconnaître c'est super
important et ça c'est une des rares
choses qui a évolué depuis les émeutes
de 2005
la présence des minorités dans la pub
échoue c'est pas pour rien la pub a
compris ça la pub a compris que pour
vendre il fallait de la diversité il est
temps que la réplique à cher mais c'est
un marché et au moins ce soir avec la
réalité donc il faudrait que la
république comprenne ça et qu'elle
trouve des leviers pour que l'un
représentant les décideurs que soi même
dans le milieu audiovisuel appartient
qui puisque cette diversité soit juste
naturellement fait que ce soit une
évidence et que ce soit pas forcément
des quotas imposés après parfois de voix
se voir du côté pour que ça à mon sens
on voit pour les femmes
ah bah écoute et voilà je suis donc le
quota de ce plateau femme est en plus un
peu basel et bien écoutez merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à ce débat j'espère
que on aura pu vous donner quelques
petits petits petites informations
complémentaires sur cette question
extrêmement complexe qu'est l'identité
nom se retrouve la semaine prochaine et
on va cette fois ci avoir un débat sur
la personne de bernard tapie tout un
programme